can anyone watching this tell me what a
republican economic plan is
and tell me who is pushing it and what
it would do for the country
anyone
the answer is no you can't because such
a thing doesn't exist
I am 40 years old throughout my lifetime
Republicans
have had one plan other than outside of
culture War stuff I'm talking about one
actual legislative plan my entire life
that one plan has been to cut
taxes
it's been trickle-down economics my
entire life every time Republicans get
power the first thing they want to do is
cut taxes we've already seen the
Republican majority in the House of
Representatives propose cutting taxes
again extending the Trump tax cuts
it doesn't work